Herkeslere selamlar Efendim ben Deniz
Mehmet hocanız 9 sınıf tayfam nasılsın
iyi misin afiyette misin Keyifler Umarım
yerindedir dedim şimdi seninle birlikte
MEB'in gerçekten diye gittiği yerde
Halbuki bomba gibi soruları patlattığı
yerde Konuyu çok ayrıntılı anlatmadığı
yerde biz inanılmaz ayrıntıya gireceğiz
burada kafada zerre soru işareti
bırakmayacağız efsanevi sorular
çözeceğiz Çünkü sen artık bir rm
tayfasına zaten yazılılardan yüksek
notları alacak İnşallah o yüzleri
yakacağız ama bizim derdimiz sadece 100
almak değil bizim derdimiz bundan 4 yıl
sonra üniversite sınavı değişirse
değişsin umrumuzda değil En azından bu
konuları sağlam bir şekilde bittiğimiz
hangi tip soru gelirse gelsin yapabilmek
Biz ona Hazırlanıyoruz Biz derece
tayfayı rm Tayfa Sen derece tayfasını mı
o zaman elimizde kalem önümüzde Video
ders notları gönder gelsin yeni başlık
hocam dedik 4 sayfa anlatacaklarım var
sana çok ayrıntılı sayı kümelerinin
özellikleri demiştik ilk olarak neyle
başlıyorum sıralama özelliği ile
başlıyorum sonrasında arada olma
özelliği falanı filandı yola devam
edeceğiz nedir bu sıralama özelliği
Hocam ne anlama geliyor bir kümedeki
elemanlar birbiriyle
karşılaştırılabilir büyüklük küçüklük
anlamında üzerinde belli özelliklere
sahip bir sıralama ilişkisi
tanımlanabilir mesela 1 sayısı 2 sayısı
3 sayısı 4 sayısı bak ne yaptım sıralı
söyledim Bunlar hangi kümenin elemanları
doğal sayıların aynı zamanda tam
sayıların O halde doğal sayılarda tam
sayılar Arda sıralı kümedir der miyim
hocam deriz Çünkü Onlarda bir sıralama
tanımlı büyüklük küçüklük ilişkisi var
aynısı rasyonel sayılar içinde var mı
var aynısı irrasyonel sayılar içinde var
mı Aslında yazmadım Buray ama İrrasyonel
sayılarda da var aynısı o zaman Gerçek
sayılar için yani gerçel sayılarda bütün
reel sayılarda Sen bir sıralama
yapabilirsin büyüklük küçüklük olarak
karşılaştırabilirsiniz
sanal sayılar imajiner sayılar
dediğimizde onlarda büyüklük küçüklük
karşılaştırması yok demek ki her sayı
kümesi de karşılaştırılamayacak sıralama
anlamında ama bizim şu an çalışacağımız
bütün elemanlar karşılaştırılacak şimdi
a ve b sayıları için İlk olarak şunu
söyleyeceğim a kü B'den B de küçü A'dan
ise AB B ifadelerinden Yalnız bir tanesi
Doğrudur Yani sen bir sıralama yaparken
ya A B'den küçüktür ya B A'dan küçüktür
ya da a B'ye eşittir Bu üç durumdan biri
gerçekleşmek zorunda geldim 2 numaralı
maddeye hocam bunları ezbere bilecek
miyiz Hayır canım öyle ezbere falan
bilmene gerek yok 1 numara 2 numaralı
Matta a < eş A'dan her zaman öyledir
hangi kümede mesela doğal sayılar
kümesini alsam 3 < eş 3 diyebilir miyim
Evet bak birbirinin aynısından aynı
sayılar birbirinden küçük eşittir aynı
zamanda hocam tam sayılarda mesela -5
küş -5 yazar mıyım yazarsın 1/2 aynı
zamanda 1/2 küçük eşit midir yazarsın
bak sıralama bağlantısını kurallarını
sağlıyor güzel arkadaşım Peki hocam reel
sayılarda mesela İrrasyonel bir reel
sayı sayıyı seçsem √3 yazsam yazamadım
ha √3 < eş √3 diyebilir miyim Vallahi
dersin hiçbir sıkıntı yok Şimdi geldik
kaç numaraya 3 numaraya 3 numarada ilk
maddemiz a < b Tamam B de ü eş a İsa her
zaman a B'ye ne olmak zorunda eşit olmak
zorunda şimdi bak bana öyle iki sayı bul
desem ki mesela 2 = 5 5 < 2 yazabilir
misin Hayır yazamam hangi sayı aynı
zaman Kendinden küçük eşittir Tabii ki
kendisi O halde 2 2'ye eşittir Bak
buraya bir sayı yazmak istiyorsan x
y'den küçük eşit y de ü eş x olabilmenin
tek şartı tek kuralı bu iki sayının
sadece birbirine eşit olduğu durumlarda
sağlanır başka durumda sağlanmaz Bunu
söylemeye çalışıyor 3 madde geldim 4
maddeye 4 madde ne diyor bize a k B'den
B de küçük c'den A da c'den küçük olmak
zorundadır misal Sen kardeşinden
büyüksün Ben de senden büyüğüm
otomatikman Ben senin kardeşinden
büyüğüm aynı mantığa geliyor 3 5'ten
yani 3 5'ten küçük 3 7'den küçük o zaman
5 ile 7 arasında bir sıralama
yazabilirim hocam 5 de 7'den küçüktür
tamam mı √6 8'den küçük √6 √10 küçükse
He hocam √8 de √10 danan ne olmak
zorunda küçük olmak zorunda dedim
Anlaştık mı ö 10'dan küçüktür dedim ama
aslında bunu asıl yazarken şöyle
yazmakta fayda var √6 < √8 √8 < ö10
dersem He şöyle daha doğru oldu Ne
dersin √6 < √10 yazarım aynı mantıkla 3
< 5'ten hocam 5 de küç 7 dersem mantıken
3 de 7'den küçüktür der miyim derim tam
olarak demek istediğim Aslında Madde 4
madde de bu Gelsin bakalım 5 madde
baktık 5 maddemiz bize o ne diyormuş
beraber okuyalım onu da eşitsizliğin her
iki tarafına aynı sayı eklenir veya
çıkarılırsa eşitsizliğin yönünde
herhangi bir değişiklik Olmaz Aslında bu
eşitsizliklerin çözüm kümelerini bulmak
için bizde bir taktik Örneğin a < b
olsun Ben her iki tarafa C eklersem
eşitsizliğin yönü dikkat etle Aynen
kaldı Hayır hocam a k b Ama ben her
taraftan C'yi çıkaracağım eşitsizlik
Aynen kalır ne demek istiyoruz hemen
örnek üstünden 7 bir kere 8'den küçük
müdür küçüktür her tarafa kaçı ekliyorum
3 ekliyorum eşitsizliğin yönü değişmez
gerçekten 7'ye 3 ekledim 10 88'e 3
ekledim 11 Bak gerçekten eşitsizliğin
yönü değişmedi hocam -9 ve 2 -9 danan 1
çıkarırsam ya da 2'den 1 çıkarırsam
eşitsizliğin yönü değişmez gerçekten -9
-1 daha -10 yaptı 2'den 1 çıktı 1 kaldı
Nedir -10 < 1'dir yani buradaki
sıralamada da herhangi bir değişiklik
olmayacaktır oldu mu gelsin altıncısı
her tarafa istediğimiz sayıyı ekleyip
çıkarabiliyoruz bu güzel Peki her tarafı
istediğimiz sayıyla çarpıp bölebilir mu
orada bir sınır var eşitsizliğin her iki
tarafını ne yapabilirsin pozitif bir
sayıyla çarpıp bölersen eşitsizlik yine
yön değiştirmiyor ne demek bu hemen
görelim C 0'dan büyük a 0'dan a da B'den
küçük olsun her tarafı pozitif bir C
sayısıyla çarptım eşitsizlik yön
değiştirmedi C 0'dan Büyük yani pozitif
bir sayı a B'den küçük olsun her taraf
neye böldüm C'ye böldüm eşitsizlik yön
değiştirmiyor pozitif bir sayı ya
bölünce ya da çarpınca 4 6'dan küçük mü
küçük her tarafı 3le çarparsam
eşitsizlik yön değiştirmez gerçekten 4 K
3 12 < 3 kere 6 18 gördün mü herhangi
bir değişiklik olmadı -12 - 6'dan
küçüktür -12 yi de - 6'yı da 2'ye bölsem
pozitif sayıya bölüyorsun hocam
eşitsizlik yön değiştirmez ve gerçekten
şunu böldüğümde cevap ne geldi -6 K şunu
böldüğümde c ne geldi -3 gerçekten
eşitsizlik yön değiştirmedi Şimdi geldik
sıkıntılı noktaya hani buraya gelene
kadar eşitsizlik hiç yön
değiştirmiyorsa FI ne ile çarpıyorum C
ile çarpıyorum eşitsizlik Ne oldu Dikkat
et ab'den küçüktü ama negatif bir
sayıyla çarptığım için eşitsizliğin yönü
değiştirdi aynı şekilde C 0'dan küçük a
da B'den küçük her tarafı negatif C
sayısına bölersem Sonuç olarak
eşitsizlik ne yaptı dikkat et yön
değiştirecek hocam bunun yönü aynı
kalmış Aman neyim Aman neyim bunun yönü
böyle olacak dizgi hatası var o dizgi
hatası Senin elindeki pdfte yoktur
Eminim bu şekilde düzelteceksin
düzelttik mi peki gel şimdi soruyu
çözelim 4 5'ten küçük her tarafı ne ile
çarpıyorum -2 ile Bak inan eşitsizliğin
yönü bu olacak peki Nasıl oluyor hocam
çarp bu 2 arkadaşı ek -8 yaptı çarp bu 2
arkadaşı -10 yaptı gerçekten -8 -10
danan büyük değil mi büyük hocam olay
bitmiştir abi ya da -9 -6 her tarafı
neye bölüyorum dikkat et hangi sayıya
böldüğüm Önemli -3'ün hocam negatif bir
sayıya bölersen eşitsizlik ne yapar yön
değiştirir inanmam hocam ya yap işlemi
yap bunun işlemini -3 yap bunun işlemini
-2 e gerçekten -2 -3'ten büyük oldu lan
niye öyle oldu eşitsizlik niye yön
değişti
bir dakika buradan -3 geldi Her tarafı
-3'ün
eşitsizlik yön değiştirmesi lazım iki
tarafı da Ha eksi olur mu hocam desene
ya biz her tarafı negatif sayıya bölünce
değerler Ne oldu pozitif oldu haliyle 3
de 2'den ne olacaktır büyük olacaktır
bir an ben bile kendimden şüphe ettim
ama şüphe edecek bir durum yok hocam
eşitsizliklerde negatif sayıyla çarpmak
bölmek eşitsizliğin yönünü değiştirir
eşitsizliğin yönünün değiştiği bir durum
daha var Eğer senin elindeki a x b 0'dan
büyük A da B'den büyük olsun Daha
doğrusu B de A'dan büyük olsun her iki
tarafa takla attırırsın eşitsizlik ne
yaparmış yön değiştirilmiş bu önemli
yine a B'den büyük olsun bu sefer ben
yine her iki tarafa takla atts Ne oldu
eşitsizlik ne yapar yön değiştirmiş bu
çok önemli bak 2 3'ten küçük ikisine de
takla attır 1/2 1/3 eşitsizlik yön
değiştirir -7 -10 danan büyük ikisine de
takla attır He hocam - 1/7 - 1/10 danan
daha küçük bir sayıdır dedik bunlar
önemli ayrıntılar geldim hem örneklerle
ilerlemiş oluyoruz ki konuyu da böyle
İyice bir kavramış oluyoruz geldim 9
özelliğimiz eğer 0 A'dan küçük a da
B'den küçükse A'nın üstüne n dereceden
kuvvetle B'nin üstüne n dereceden kuvvet
atsan da eşitsizlik yön değiştirmez ama
n burada pozitif bir tam sayı olmak
zorunda misal 2 5'ten küçük müdür
küçüktür 2nin 3 kuvveti 5 3 kuvveti
gerçekten eşitsizlik yön değiştirmedi
istersen dene yaz yan tarafına 2in 3
kuvveti 8 5'in 3 kuvveti 125 gerçekten
125 8'den büyüktür geldim 1/3 1/2 küçük
e
1/3 ifadesinin karesi
1/2 karesinden küçük mü büyük mü işte
burada eşitsizlik yön değiştirdi neden
karesini alınca Burası ne oldu 1/9 oldu
hocam Pardon yön değiştirmedi yön
değiştir dedik ya burada Ne oldu 1/2
karesi nedir 1/4 gerçekten 1/4 1/9 danan
daha büyük bir sayıdır her tarafın aynı
dereceden kuvvetini pozitif kuvvetini
alırsan eşitsizlik yön değiştirmez
geldim 10 numaraya Bu bir biraz kritik
bir durum A 0dan büyük Ama 1den küçük
olsun A'nın n dereceden kuvveti A'dan
her daim küçüktür 0 la 1 aralığındaki
Bir sayının n 1'den büyük pozitif
kuvvetlerine aldığında o kuvvetler her
zaman A'nın kendisinden küçüktür Peki
nasıl oluyor Hocam bu diyeceksin Örneğin
bak 0 la 1 arasında ben kaçı alabilirim
1/3 alırım benim a dediğim sayı bu
1/3 karesi gerçekten A'nın kendisinden
küçüktür niye 1/3 karesi 1/9 durur 1/9
1/3 gerçekten küçüktür buraya örnekle
açıkladım Peki hocam a kare denen ifade
A'dan küçüktür ne zaman a ifadesi 0 la 1
aralığında olduğu zaman bak gerçek
Aslında onu burada örneğini vermiş oldum
Şurada da örneğini göstermiş oldum Peki
hocam a değeri a kareden küçüktür ne
zaman a değeri ya negatif olacak misal -
1/3 karesi ne yaptı 1/9 oldu O halde -
1/3 kimden küçük 1/9 danan Yani
karesinden daha küçük ya da o a değeri
pozitif bir sayı Ama 1den büyük bir
pozitif sayıysa misal A sayısı 5 olsun
5in karesi nedir 25'tir o zaman 5 kimden
küçüktür 25'ten küçüktür Yani bir sayı
karesinden küçüktür ama ne zaman o sayı
1'den büyük ya da 0'dan küçük olduğunda
bir sayı karesinden küçüktür ne zaman o
sayı 0 la 1 aralığında olduğuna göre
işte buradan bazen üniversite sınav
sorularında böyle ücra sorular geldi
zamanında ama şimdi benim derdim bu
eşitsizlik mantığını kümelerde sayı
kümelerinde sıralama mantığıyla sana
anlatmak x elemanıdır reel Say Yani
bütün sayılar olabilir bu eşitsizliğin
çözüm kümesini arıyorsun Aslında bu eş
sizin çözüm kümesinde Biz bunu buraya
atıyorduk hatırlıyor Mus Aslında
matematik öyle bir şey değil bunu alıp
oraya falan atamıyorsun Ne lan bu çöp mü
Öyle atıyorsun abi her iki tarafa
Aslında ne ekliyorum + 3 ekliyorum niye
oradaki -3'ten kurtulmak için izle beni
cırt Sınana cırt Sana bunlar gitti mi
gitti burada Ne kaldı 5x karşıda Ne oldu
9 He şimdi mantığı anladın değil mi
eşitsizlik her tarafa aynı sayıyı
ekleyince yön değiştirir mi
değiştirmez her tarafı şimdi xin önü
katsayıya bölüyorum böldüğüm sayı
pozitif bir sayı olduğu için eşitsizlik
yön değiştirmez Bunlar kritik cümleler
bu Beşler gitti x < Ne kaldı 99/5 Peki
bu 9/5 i Ben sayı doğrusunda gösterecek
olsam şöyle mi gösteririm bak 99/5
burası nereyi karalıyorum bu tarafı
karalıyorum arkadaş nereye kadar eksi
sonsuza kadar peki çözüm kümesi yaz
dediğimde Nereden geliyorsun eksi sonsuz
aralığından 99/5 açık aralığına kadar
geliyorum Bunlar bizim için çok değerli
sorular Şimdi burada soruda Önemli olan
ben sana bir noktayı göstereyim mi Bak x
elemanıdır reel sayı dediği için böyle
yazdım gel öyle kurtulamazsın x
elemanıdır neresi diyor rasyonel sayı
diyor öyle herkese alamazsın diyor
dikkat diyor elinde böyle bir ifade var
Ne yapacaksın hocam Önce Bu paydadaki
3en kurtulacağız karşıya çarpım olarak
atarım sakın içler dışlar yok aslında ne
yapıyormuşum her tarafı 3le çarpıyorum
pozitif sayıyla çarpmak eşitsizliğin
yönünü bozmaz burada Ne kaldı 7x - 1 >
bunu dağıtarak gel 3 K 4 ne geldi 14x 3
kere 5'ten ne geldi 15 geldi bu 7xi bu
tarafa attım burada Ne kaldı 3 kere 4
12x l ne 14x şurası 12x olacak 12x 7x
çıktı Ne kaldı 5x kaldı bunu bu tarafa
attım ne yaptı -16 yaptı Şimdi ne
yapacağım hocam -
16/5 B x'ten şimdi dur Normal şartlarda
bunu bana sayı doğrusunda gösteremezsin
Neden gösteremezsin benim sayım -16 /
5'ten küçük hocam nasıl gösteremem işte
burası Hayır eğer x elemanıdır reel sayı
olsaydı böyle ama x bir rasyonel sayı
yani Şuradaki bir noktadaki sayı benim
bir rasyonel sayı olmayabilir o aralıkta
bir İrrasyonel sayı var onu Ne
yapacaksın abi Ha o zaman bunu yazarken
şöyle yapacağım çözüm kümesi x' oluşacak
Öyle ki bu x' kimden küçük - 166/1 küçük
ama x' L kimin elemanı rasyonel
sayıların elemanı Vallahi sınavda
gelirse üzer ama sen üzülmüyorsun Sen
rym tayfasını kümesinin bu tarz
sorularda Önemli olan noktası nerede
istiyor Abi bu arada hiçbir şey
yazmadığını düşün burada o zaman reel
sayılarda buluyorsun Eğer yazıyorsa bir
şey orada buluyorsun misal Bak buna x
elemanı da Z olmak üzere çözüm kümesini
nerede vermiş hocam tam sayılarda vermiş
öyle kafama göre her şeyi alan tam bak
nasıl çözeceğim soruyu 4x ya Bak şunu
yapmak hata değildir Ama benim Az önce
öğrendiğim kurallar bana ne diyor her
tarafa 8 ekle bunlar zaten gidiyor diyor
Aslında bir nevi de o -8 karşıya + 8
olarak attım 18 her tarafı 4E böldüm x
üş 4'e böldüm 9/2 kaldı Şimdi 9/2 nedir
4,5 sayısıdır benim sayım 45'ten büyük
tam sayılar olacak 5 olabilir 6 olabilir
7 olabilir 8 olabilir nokta nokta nokta
Demek ki bunun çözüm kümesini yazarken
mesela eleman olarak yazarsam nasıl
yazacağım 5 6 7 8 nokta nokta nokta
sonsuza kadar gidiyor ama sadece tam
sayılar alabiliyor hocam bunun çözüm
kümesini sayı doğrusunda şöyle mi
gösterirdim nereden başlıyorum açık
Aralık 9/2 hocam kapalı diyor abi
kapatsan Eğer böyle çizersen bu x
elemanıdır reel sayıyı kabul etmektir
bak biz x'i reel sayı kabul etmedik tam
sayı kabul ettik benim çözüm küm Yani bu
değil o reel sayılardaki çözüm kümesi
ama yapılan en büyük hata bu Sen bu
hataya düşme Peki bu çözüm kümesini
başka nasıl gösterirdim xlerator
çözüyorum x'i bir tarafa toplayalım sen
bu tarafa gel sen bu tarafa gel -7 -9 =
5x - 3x Tamam mıyız hocam her tarafa 9
çıkartmamız gerekmiyor mu ya Öyle
gerekiyor da gerek yok Böyle de
çözebiliyor bu soruları -16 K eş kimden
2x her tarafı 2'ye böldüm -8 kü eş
kimden x'ten eğer soru reel sayılarda
olsaydı sen çözüm kümesine şunu
yazacaktın diyecektin ki bak bu tarafa
kadar artı sonsuza kadar gidiyoruz ama x
elemanı da reel sayı deseydi benim sorum
reel sayı değil bir daha hatırlatıyorum
benim sorum doğal sayılarda geçiyor O
halde çözüm kümesi diyorum eşittir
diyorum x' derden oluşacak Öyle ki bu x'
L kimden büyük eşit olacak -8 ve x'i
nereden alacağım Doğal sayılardan bunu
da yazabilirsin ama ben sana daha
Garanti bir şey söyleyeyim ya garanti
değil de Ulan zaten x denen Sayı doğal
sayıysa -8 büyükse ilk hangi sayı var 1
2 3 yaz yerine gör doğal sayıların hepsi
aslında çözüm kümesi kimmiş bütün doğal
sayılar u bayağı farklı bir soruydu bu
Umarım anlaşmışım ilginç bir soruydu
şimdi biraz daha kurallara yönelik
sorularla gidelim pozitif bir x sayısı
için x sayısı 1/7 küçük ise 1/2 in
alabileceği en küçük tam sayı değeri
nedir Bak x küçükmüş kimden 1/7 Eğer x
pozitif bir sayıysa takla ırına
eşitsizlik ne yapıyordu yön
değiştiriyordu yön değiştirsin takla
attırdım 1/2 oldu akla attırdım yön
değiştirdi burası 7 oldu
1/7 x'in alabileceği en küçük tam sayı
ya hocam ben 1/2 alabileceği en küçük
tam sayı için ne söyleyebilirim 7'den
büyükse 8 olur diyeceksin olabilecek en
küçük tam sayı değeri 8'dir dedim gönder
gelsin sıradaki Soru 6 soru x y z nasıl
sayılar tam sayılar önemli nokta sorunun
güzelliğine bak sınav sorusu adayıdır
söyleyeyim güzel bir sınav sorusu adayı
olur Z x'ten küçük Tamam hocam y 0dan
büyük ama Z - y'den küçük x + y + z
toplamının en küçük değeri nedir Bir
kere Elimizde bu var mı var hocam Z
denen değer x'ten küçük bu cepte
elimizde bir de bak burası var Şurayı
alalım y < z - y'den ne yapabilirim bunu
karşıya atabilirim karşıda ne olur 2
tane y olur 2 tane y kimden küçük Z'den
küçük hocam Süpersin bir şey
söyleyeceğim Z Z denen değer 2 y'den
büyükse y de pozitifse eğer Demek ki x
denen değer de bunlardan büyük olmaz mı
Çünkü x denen değer Z'den büyüktü hocam
kısaca aralarında şöyle bir sıralama var
mıdır y en küçük sayı sonra Z sayısı
sonra da x sayısı Bu arada y kimden
büyük 0dan Demek ki Bütün sayılar 0'dan
büyük y en küçük alabileceği tam sayı
değeri 0 olamıyorsa kaç olur 1 Z en
küçük kaç olur 2 dediğinde taml çek
patladı Hadi geçmiş olsun Sazanın Abi bu
soru sazan sorusu Sen şimdi Y'ye 1
verirsen bak 2 x 1 küçükse Z'den 2
kimden küçük Z'den O halde Z'nin
alabileceği en küçük sayı 2 olmaz ezbere
soru çözme 3 olur peki Z de x'ten küçük
olacak bir sonraki tam sayı kaç 4 biz
bunların nesini arıyoruz toplamının en
küçük değerini verebildiğimiz
dedim gönder gelsin sıradaki olduğuna
göre x'in alabileceği en büyük tam sayı
değeri kaçtır bir dakika X'in en büyük
tam sayı değerini arıyorum ya o zaman ne
diyorum Burada takla attıracağım abi
burada takla attırdım Evet hocam takla
attırın ca eşitsizlik ne oluyordu yön
değiştiriyordu takla attırdım Burası ne
oldu 33/7 oldu peki bana şunu söyle 33/7
nasıl bir sayı 4 kere 7 28 5 kere 7 35
geçiyor o zaman 4 defa verelim 4 kere 7
28 çıkarttım Ne kaldı 5 50 yani 50 küsür
7 kere 7 49 ha süper 4,7 N nokta diye
giden bir sayı var elimde ben x'in
alabileceği en büyük tam sayı değerini
istiyorum 4,7 Küçük x'in alabileceği tam
sayı değeri nedir kesinlikle 4'tür dah
yani alabileceği en büyük değer 4'tür
müthiş bir soru daha şimdi hocam
sınavlarda yeni nesil soru gelirse Bizim
Hoca yeni nesil soruyor bizim hoca zor
soruyor Abi bu dakikadan itibaren
çözeceğiz soru Hem yeni nesil hem Yeri
geldiği şu 5 soru var ya derece Tayfa
sorusu haberin olsun yeni nesil soru a
ve b şehirleri arasında iki farklı yolun
uzunlukları verildi birinci yol daha
kısa olduğuna göre şimdi Birinci yolun
kısa olması demek ikinci Yolun daha uzun
olduğu anlamına gelir mi gelir O halde
1ci yol küçüktür 2 yol yazar mıyım
yazarım aralarında büyüklük küçüklük
ilişkisi kurarım 4A dediğim değer 7A -
48' küçük hocam birinci yol daha kısa
olduğuna göre A'nın en küçük tam şimdi
a'yı buradan çekmeye çalışım seni bu
tarafa çektim 3A geldi Seni bu tarafa
attım ne geldi 48 geldi doğru muyuz Her
tarafı kaça bölüyorum 3'e bölüyorum a'yı
yalnız bırakıyorum eşitsizlik hiç yön
değiştirmedi 16 3 kere 6 18 evet a bü 16
Sen benden ney istiyorsun A'nın en küçük
tam sayı değerini o zaman A'nın
alabileceği en küçük tam sayı değeri
16'dan büyük olacağına göre kaçtır
17'dir dedim vurdum cevabı gönderin
gelsin dedim yeni nesil soru lazım bize
hocam Şakir neca Remzi'nin boyları ile
ilgili aşağıdaki bilgiler veriliyor
Şakir Remzi'den uzun gel bunu hemen
harflerle yazalım Şakir Remzi'den uzunsa
Şakir'in boyu Remzi'den büyüktür
Necati'nin boyu Remzi'nin boyuna eşit
veya Remzi'nin boyundan kısadır şimdi
veya kısa olması demek Necati küçük eş R
demektir yani oradaki remzen demektir
Buna göre aşağıdaki soruları
cevaplayacağım ş Remzi Necati Remzi
Şakir Necati'nin boylarını karşılaştır
önce şunun Şakir Remzi'nin zaten yazdık
bak Şakir'in boyu Remzi'nin boyundan
büyüktür hocam Necati Remzi e Necati'nin
boyu küçük eşittir kimden Remzi'den
Şakir ve Necati'ye Bakacağım şimdi ben
ne biliyorum Necati'nin boyu Remzi'nin
boyundan küçük eşit O da kimin boyundan
Küçük Şakir'in Biz burada sıralama
özelliği gereğince ne yapabiliriz deriz
ki hocam Necati'nin boyu küçüktür
Şakir'in boyu belki aklına şu gelebilir
hocam eşit olabilir mi n ile R eşit
olabilir ama bak ş kesinlikle bunlardan
büyük bir eşitlik kavramı yok olmadığı
için n kesinlikle Şen büyüktür
diyebilirsin yazacağın özellik bu Şakir
Remzi Necati'nin boylarını hangi sayı
doğrusu kümesi elemanlarıyla yani sayı
kümesi elemanlarıyla gösteririz bir kere
akıllara ilk şu gelir her zaman her
zaman hocam boydan bahsediyorsan bir
kere kesinlikle ne olur doğal sayı
olabilir doğru mu Evet doğal sayılarla
göster
hocam tam sayılarla da gösteririm Ama
niye öyle diyorsun ya negatif değer
alamaz ama olsun tam sayıların
içerisinde de yine doğal sayılar yok mu
gösterirsin en nihayetine ya bunların
boyları buçuklu çıkamaz mı yani rasyonel
sayıyla gösterilemez mi gösterilebilir
ya bunların boyu efendime söyleyeyim 10
kö3 bir değer Gelemez mi ölü değer gelir
nasıl hocam Ben hayatımda duymadım olsun
lan gelir ya istersem zorlarsam böyle
inanılmaz hassas çok hassas bir metre
var benim elimde Ben bunu kök 3te
ölçemez miyim öyle bir uzunluk ki orası
3 3 3 3 3 sonsuza kadar giden bir
uzunluktan böyle ayarında tutturamamış
olabilir abi hepsi olabilir geldim ya
bunun boyu bütün reel sayılardan
istediğim elemanları seçebilirim yani
reel sayılarla da gösterebilirim bu ü
kişinin de boylarına 15 cm daha artarsa
Şakir Remzi Necati'nin boyları
arasındaki sıralama ne olur Normalde
aralarındaki Bor sıralaması şu şekilde
miydi Peki ben diyorum ki abi her
tarafın boyu 15 artarsa her tarafa aynı
sayıyı ekleyince bizim kurallarımız
gereğince burada sıralamada bir
değişiklik olur mu Olmaz boy sıralaması
aynı kalır sıralamada herhangi bir
değişiklik olmaz geldim 10 soruya günün
böyle güzel sorularından biri sınav
sorusu adayıdır kendisi a b c soru
bankalarında eşit miktarda soru
bulunmaktadır şimdi a soru bankasında a
tane soru b soru bankasında B tane C
soru bankasında C tane ama a b c
birbirine eşit Remzi bu soru bankasından
sırasıyla x y z tane soru çözdüğünde
çözülmemiş en çok soru a soru bankasında
şimdi a soru bankasında şimdi hepsinde
eşit sayıda soru vardı ya şöyle yapalım
mı hepsinde M tane soru olsun Anlaştık
mı A soru bankasında kalan sorular kalan
soruların sayısını nasıl bulursun M tane
soru var x tanesini çözdü hocam güzel b
soru bankasında kalan soruların adedini
nasıl bulursun b soru bankasında M tane
soru var m - y tane kaldı C soru
bankasında kalan soruların adedini nasıl
bulursun M tane soru var Z tanesini
çözdü m - z en çok çözülmemiş soru a
soru bankasında yani m - x en büyüğü en
az soru c soru bankasında m - z en az
soru burada kalıyor Demek ki ortanca
soru Nerede kaldı b soru bankasında
kaldı Şimdi benim elimde böyle bir
sıralama var benden x y z'yi sıralamamı
istiyor abi nasıl olacak bu istersen
sayı ver bak 10 10 10 yazdım şimdi bunun
en büyük olabilmesi için X'in en küçük
y'nin ortanca Z'nin en büyük olması
gerekmiyor mu yani birbirleriyle ters
işliyorlar ya da ne yapabilirsin Bak her
yeri eksi ile çarparsın bunun
matematiksel bir çözümü de var - m + x
eksi ile çarpmak ne yapar eşitsizliğin
yönünü değiştirir hocam içerideki
işaretler de değişti şimdi her tarafa ne
ekliyorum M ekliyorum M ekledim gitti M
ekledim gitti M ekledim gitti geriye ne
kaldı x < y o da < Z kaldı Gerçekten de
benim sıralamam ne olmalıydı bu şekilde
olmalıydı dedim mis gibi 10 tane soru
üstüne konu anlatım canavar gibi
bitirdik bitti mi soru Avcısı bölümü var
dedim ya bizim videolar inanılmaz
ayrıntı bizim videolarda çözmedi imiz
soru tarzı kalmaz şimdi gerçek sınav
soruları ayarında gerçekten bize
sorulacak soruları istiyor musun işte
geliyor o zaman ne diyoruz soru Avcısı
bölümü için gönder gelsin soru Avcısı
bölümünde 5 tane çok güzel sorum var
şimdi bunları seri halde birlikte
çözeceğiz x bir tam sayı için verilen
eşitsizlikte x sayısının alabileceği en
büyük değeri arıyoruz ne yaparsın hocam
İçler dışlar yapmamaya çalış arkadaşım
her zaman bizim bu eşitsizliklerde böyle
aynı tarafta aynı sayılarla çarp çarptım
hocam 1 - 3x > -14 doğru mu -3 x'i
buraya -14 bu tarafa 1 + 14 > 3x kabul
14 bir daha ne yaptı 15 yaptı neyden
büyük 3x büyük her tarafı neye bölüyorum
3'e bölüyorum bu 3'ler birbirini yedi
şunlar gitti burada Ne kaldı 5 kaldı o
halde 5 kimden büyüktür hocam 5 x'ten
büyüktür x'in alabileceği en büyük tam
sayıyı bana söylesene x hocam olsa olsa
4'tür ya Daha fazlası olamaz ki Çünkü 5
olamıyor O zaman en fazla 4 alır dedim
Doğru cevap Edirne Yukarıdaki
eşitsizliği sağlayan ne arıyorum pozitif
x tam sayıları kaç tanedir pozitif
olanları soruyorum Lütfen dikkat şimdi
paydada 3 var her tarafa o zaman ne ile
çarpmak gerekiyor 3 ile çarpalım ki
paydadan kurtul yukarıda 2x - 1 < 3 K
5'ten 15 kaldı amaç x'i yalnız bırakmak
2x < 15 + 1 yani 2x = 16 her tarafı 2'ye
böldüm x < eş 8 Normal şartlarda Sen
88'i alırsın 7'yi alırsın 6 alırsın 5'i
4'ü 3'ü 2'yi 1'i 0'ı eks gider ama ben
neleri istiyorum pozitifleri Bak
pozitifler burada bu kadar kaç tane
pozitif tam sayı değeri alabilir 8 tane
doğru cevap Ne oldu B seçeneği oldu Aman
neim soruları çok dikkatli okuyorsun
Böyle karşına geldiğinde okumazsan abi
gidiyor zaten mükemmel bir soru Ben
sınav sorusu olarak abi bunu sorabilirim
bak ne çok zor bir soru ne çok kolay bir
soru tam sınav ayarında bir soru ya x
bir tam sayı Ali x yaşında Veli 3x -8
Burçak 2x + 2 Kasım 4x -14 yaşında Veli
burçak'tan Burçak da Kasım'dan küçük
olduğuna göre Ali kaç yaşında bir dakika
hocam Ne diyorsun Veli burçak'tan Küçük
Veli küçüktür burçak'tan Burçak da
Kasım'dan küçük Aa sıralama buymuş hocam
Peki Velinin yaşı neydi 3x - 8di
küçükmüş kimden 2x + 2'den Bu da kimden
küçük 4X - 18'den küçük Şimdi burada
sıralama yapacaksın genelde Böyle üçlü
görürsen bir burayı al güzel arkadaşım
Bir de burayı ayrı ayrı al ayrı ayrı
alırsan çözersin 3x - 8 3x - 8 küçükmüş
2x + 2'den önce bunu çözeceğim Sonra 2x
+ 2 küç 4x - 18'den Sonra da kalkıp bunu
çözeceğiz hadi başlayalım 2 x'i bu
tarafa attım 8'i bu tarafa attım burada
x kaldı burada 10 Demek ki x denen sayı
10'dan küçük peki geldim bu tarafa 2x bu
tarafa attım -18 bu tarafa attım 20 oldu
Burası ne oldu 2x kaldı 2x mi kaldı
eee bir dakika 4x bu tarafa attım 2x
Kaldı 18 Burada da 18 2 daha 20 oldu Bir
İşlem hatası yaptık mı diye bakıyorum
yalnız 3x - 8 Tamamdır < 2x a + 14' müş
Hocam bu Ben de diyorum saçma geliyor
cevap yukarıda + 144 yazıyor orada şur
pardon -14 yazıyor şuraya -14 yazalım
şimdi güzel oldu şurası ne yaptı 16
yaptı her tarafı 2'ye böldüm x denen
sayı kimden büyük 8'den Şimdi bana bu
ikisini birleştir x 10'dan küçük hocam
ama 8'den büyüktür hocam Anlaştık mı
mevzuyu çözdük mü 8 ile kaç arasında 10
arasında o halde X'in cevabı nedir
99'dur hocam x = kesin 9 abi x nereden
biliyorsun 9 olduğunu tam sayı diyor 8
ile 10 arasında kim var var 9 Ali kaç
yaş e Ali x yaşında Ya sen bana 99'u
soruyorsun o yüzden lezzetli bir soru
Hani veliyi Verdi burçağı verdi kasımı
Verdi Ulan gitti Ali'yi sordu Yemezler
rem Tayfa yemez gelsin şimdi Geride
bıraktığımız Bir hafta boyunca
Gaziantep'te en düşük hava sıcaklığı -5
en yüksek hava sıcaklığı 11 derecedir
Geride bırakılan haftanın günlerinden
birinde hava sıcaklığı 3x - 2/5 derece
olduğuna göre x tam sayısının
alabileceği kaçç farklı değer vardır
şimdi benim hava sıcaklığım 3x - 2/5 D
olmuş ama bu derece -5 de olabilir yani
buna eşit de olmuş olabilir Bu aradaki
değerler de olabilir ya da 11'e de eşit
olabilir Anlaştık mı ha bu aralıkta da
olabilir hocam Benim yazmam gereken bu
şimdi X'in tam sayı aralığını arıyoruz
ilk yapmam gereken bak alttaki paydadan
kurtulmak için her tarafı neyle
çarpıyorsun 5'le pozitif sayıyla çarpmak
eşit
yön değiştirmez -25 KÇ Bunlar gitti 3x -
2 O da küç ne geldi 55 geldi şimdi
diyorum ki -2 buraya geçer mi + 2 diye
bu -2 de buraya geçer mi + 2 diye
Süpersin -25 + 2 daha ne geldi -23 < 3x
O da < + 2 bu tarafa geldiğinde ne yaptı
57 yaptı hocam her tarafı neye böleceğiz
3'e -
23/3 x O da ü eş
57/3 bir dakika Burada bazı tam sayı
değerler var onları bulmamız lazım önce
23'ü kenarda 3'e böleceğim 3 kere 7 21
çıkarttım 2 20'nin içerisinde 6 7,6 Ama
- 7,6 küç eş x'ten O da küçük eşittir
devam 57'ye Bir de neye böleceğim 3'e
bir defa var 3 çıkarttım 27 e a tam mı
bölündü harbiden 3 kere 9 27 Vallahi tam
bölündü a Burası da 0 küçü eşit kimden
19'dan Şimdi bana x'in alabileceği
değerleri söyle hocam bak 19'dan başla
19 18 nokta nokta 1 olur 0 olur -1 olur
-2 olur kaça kadar nokta nokta - 7'ye
kadar Bak -8 bu tarafta kalıyor Demek ki
-7 bu tarafta kalıyor xin alabileceği
değerler bana burada toplam kaç tane
sayı alabildiğini söylüyor tam sayı
alabildiğini söylüyor -1 ile -7 arasında
7 tane sayı var 0'ın kendisi var bir
19 arasında 19 tane var Toplamda burada
27 tane sayı vardır 27 tane sayı
olduğuna göre doğru cevabı C seçeneğidir
dedim haydi geçmiş olsun 4 soru biter
günün en zor sorusu günün derece Tayfa
sorusu bunu çözen derece tayfadan
söyleyelim Hatta Buraya yazalım Bence
bunu çözen derece
[Müzik]
tayfadan bil ki dereceye adaysın uçak 5
x - 300/2 metre yükseklikten iken bir
kişi uçaktan paraşüt ile atlıyor buradan
atlıyor 1100 metre serbest düşüş
yaptıktan sonra tam bu noktaya geliyor
ve paraşütünü açıyor buradan tamam mı bu
kişinin paraşütünü açtığı yükseklik en
az 5000 metre Şuradaki yükseklik en az
kaç metre 5000 met olduğuna göre x tam
sayısının alabileceği en küçük değer
kaçtır bir dakika x tam sayısının
değerini istiyorum En az 5.000 metre
demek ne demek benim yüksekliğ Demek ki
5.000 metreye eşit veya daha büyük demek
peki ben bu yüksekliği nasıl
hesaplayacağım hocam benim yüksekliğ
yerden full yüksekliği neresi 5x -
300/2 M şu arası 1100 M yani Şuradaki
1100 metreyi şu değerden çıkarırsam
5.000 metreyi bulur muyum bulurum hocam
Demek ki ben 5x - 300 / 2'den Neyi
çıkarıyorum 1200'ü Çıkarıyorum bu
eşitsizliği çözmem istiyor benden
inanılmaz güzel soru aldım attım karşıya
yani 5x -
300/2 ü eş karşıya artı olarak geçti
600'den Her tarafı 2 ile çarpıyorum
süperiz bitirdim bu tarafı 5x - 300 = 2
x 1 2 2 x 6 12
12.00'den -300 bu tarafa attım hocam 5x
> eş neyden
12.00'den Peki her tarafı kaça bölüyorum
5e bölüyorum ki Böylelikle X'in neyden
büyük eşit olduğunu bulacağım büyük
eşittir şunun içerisine 25 defa var 25'
imi yazdım sonuna 2 0 attım 2500 metre
ya da 2500 metreden büyüktür dedim x tam
sayısının alabileceği en küçük en küçük
değer ta kendisi olabiliyor 2500
metredir doğru cevap D seçeneği Muazzam
muazzam Muazzam harika bir günün daha
sonuna geldik artık sıralama olayını
bitirdik hemen arkasından bir ders sonra
ne yapacağız arada kalma olayına
bakacağız belki buraları okulda bizden
önde götürmüş olabilirsin daha hızlı
gitmiş olabilirsin ama yapılması gereken
bu ayrıntısı bu önemli olan nokta bunu
anlamak lütfen burayı anlamam bizim için
çok kıymetli Anlaştık mı O zaman ne
diyoruz Bir sonraki derste yeniden
Görüşeceğiz ama 9 sınıf tayfaya Biraz
kırgınım Arkadaş vallahi Şaka değil
hocam 7.000 10.000 15.000 izliyorsunuz
300 500 kişi beğeniyor Kusura bakmayın
da diğer tayfalar beğeniyor böyle olur
videolar geç gelmez ama daha bir şevkle
be Hadi sen de bir zahmet beğenirsen
hala bakıyor Bak beğen tuşuna bak
bakıyor orada duruyor L bayan şurada bir
yerde işte şurada şurada duruyor beğen
geç ya Hadi görüşelim bir sonra gidersiz
Kendine iyi bak hoş kal Hoşça
[Müzik]
kal i